so i've been out on a patrol boat with
the ukrainian navy you can see we're
just heading back into port while we
were out here on the sea of azov we saw
evidence of a russian patrol boat um
following another ship the ukrainians
say that russian patrol votes are
constantly following their ships moving
out of this port the azov sea the sea of
azov is a waterway that's supposed to be
shared equally between ukraine and
russia but the ukrainians say that the
russians have been restricting their
ability to operate in the sea to use
their port for commercial activity they
say in fact since 2014 when russia
annexed crimea the level of traffic
coming in and out of ukraine has dropped
by up to 50 percent
and for the navy it's been a huge hit
their main base was in crimea they've
obviously had to had to lose that moving
back to odessa they're now trying to
rebuild their navy rebuild their ships
and also rebuild rebuild their ability
to defend their own coastline here in
badansk they are actually renovating a
base here the uk is helping with that
effort but there is a very real risk of
uh further escalation that's why you've
got western powers meeting with russia
this week to try and um
and prevent a crisis but in ukraine they
know the threat is real they've been in
a in a conflict with russia for the past
eight years and one risk is that there
could be a new escalation on the
waterway somewhere like here where uh
the ukrainians say they are determined
to defend themselves